hey there welcome to the uplift board
and we got a great show for you today
great cast of characters as well you
know I always say that including these a
woman dedicated to editing and writing
Wikipedia pages but there's a good
reason why she's so involved I'll tell
you what's behind her story and her
unique hobby also a high school football
player who received devastating news but
did not let it stop him from winning
games plus a boy who lost a beloved
possession how a group of co-workers
came together to get it back to him all
in one piece
and is celebrating Leslie Jordan Anthony
Mason met up with the actor just two
weeks before he died tragically and
unexpectedly at the age of 67 and they
talked about the many ways he put a
smile on our faces throughout his career
all that plus our heartwarming videos
the ones you just gotta see all that's
coming up on the uplift
[Music]
hey there welcome to the uplift I'm Tony
decopal we are going to kick things off
with Wikipedia a Wikipedia search in
fact of Jess Wade she's a physicist who
spends her free time researching and
writing Wikipedia Pages for others
here's Caitlin O'Kane with her story
throughout history female scientists
engineers and mathematicians have
changed the world but while their
accomplishments have been massive their
names and their stories have rarely been
publicized despite this physician Jess
Wade says she's always been inspired by
the great women in stem who came before
her first by her mom a physician then by
her colleagues
you know whilst the number of women
professors in a physics department and
it's quite small
you're really aware and you're really
inspired by the ones that you get to
interact with so certainly being
surrounded by and and inspired by women
was really important to me discovering
who I am as a scientist when she was a
graduate student just met another
inspiring woman in stem Kim Cobb you
know she's one of those people you meet
and you're just like how can one person
be so awesome she's actually a climate
scientist at Brown University where she
works on kind of trying to understand
the impact of humans on climate change
and so when I met her I thought she is
an awesome person and I need to learn
more about her when I did a little um
search I I couldn't find any information
about her that was in in kind of one
place you know what I wanted was to find
a Wikipedia page and if Wikipedia page
wasn't that it just had an idea to start
her own unique project writing Wikipedia
Pages for diverse people in stem who
don't yet have them so so I became
really interested in ways that we could
try and improve that diversity but also
try and improve the way that we
celebrate and honor the incredible
scientists who were from historically
marginalized backgrounds so people who
are women or people of color or people
who are lgbtq plus who historically have
been underrepresented in science how can
we do more to honor them in her free
time just scours the internet to collect
information then she gets to work
writing Wikipedia Pages she's written
more than 1700 so far and it's shocking
to her that none of them had Pages
before kizmakia Corbett who's the
immunologist who developed the way to
artificially create Spike proteins to
create the moderna mRNA covered vaccine
if you think about the kind of people
who've probably had the most impact on
all of our lives in the past two years
kizzy is is way up there right she's
she's world leader in facilitating our
return to some kind of normality another
absolutely amazing person who I thought
had a kind of super interesting story
that that wasn't on media was a linguist
called Elizabeth Sid Meyer who actually
was at the Inception of the Central
Intelligence Group which became the CIA
she was there as a woman as a kind of
Pioneer in leading the way in doing
whatever sophisticated spying
Technologies America was starting to
create and leverage Jess is making a
name for herself in stem and she knows
she wouldn't be here without those who
came before her
you know Wikipedia is one small part of
this but we all have a role to play in
Making Science a more diverse and a more
fair in a more equal place you know we
know that science is going to provide
solutions to the biggest challenges that
the world faces so if you're not going
to edit Wikipedia talk about scientists
from historically marginalized groups in
your lessons talk about them with your
kids the sky's the limit we all have a
role to play in in making the world more
fair and equal
Brett Morgan was an up-and-coming player
on his high school football team when he
received some truly devastating news
news had changed his life forever but it
didn't stop him from following his dream
here CBS News is Steve Overmeyer
I think all my coaches would agree that
they didn't think I'd be playing
football again
Brant Morgan is a senior at Jericho High
School to appreciate where he is we need
to go back to where his story began two
years ago as the JV quarterback he was
like the next up and coming guy and uh
we had a fantastic season he led us to
our first win at Jericho in a couple
years then a shadow fell over his bright
future I heard a click while I was in
the shower and
I look in the mirror and I saw two golf
size probably the size of two golf balls
a size mass popping out of my neck
within days the diagnosis was clear
cancer Non-Hodgkin's lymphoma everything
just stopped and I was just in shock
Brent went directly to the hospital and
just in time I got to the emergency room
and they found out that my cancer spread
from my throat to my chest in less than
a week for the next few months he would
undergo multiple rounds of chemotherapy
I'm stuck here getting poisoned put into
my body it caused me to lose probably
almost 30 pounds I got neuropathy which
I lost feeling tips down while his
friends were enjoying the life of a high
schooler Brandt spent months relearning
how to walk so now I want you to do it
on the inside line every wobbly step
fueling his desire to return to football
I'm going to do this I'm going to wake
up tomorrow I'm going to do this I'm
going to wake up the next day I'm going
to work out and I'm gonna
just transform my body back to not only
where it was but better he grew stronger
faster better than before he didn't just
want to come back he wouldn't stop until
he was the starting quarterback
qb1 quarterback's leader the quarter if
you don't have a quarterback you can't
have a team
starting quarterback absolutely a rocky
earned absolutely well deserved well
earned and plays it well on this day
Brandt LED his team on the field against
Oceanside one of the biggest schools on
Long Island his mother Abby is at the
edge of the fence of this game that was
both inspiring and gut-wrenching as a
mom is it tough to watch your son
getting tackled yes yes it's very hard
it's disturbing but I have to put it
back again in my head that when a year
ago he couldn't even do any of this and
a year and a half ago we were in the
hospital so look at him now he's on the
field he's living his dream this is him
this is all he ever wanted this is Grant
Morgan and I couldn't be prouder he is
my my qb1 forever Brant took some shots
in this game
but nothing hits as hard as cancer a
fact he's reminded of every chemo
treatment having a good time like
hitting some people on the fields like
as hard as it is for some people to
watch like my mom's watching me get hit
after everything because I've been hit
with a lot worse and even though it
wasn't a win they had moments to
celebrate and reflect on the bigger
picture you're gonna go through so many
dark times especially throughout
something so crucial like this like life
is a mindset itself and I've learned
that in so many different ways now that
like when I'm facing like I'm going
through a war like I'm going to turn
I'm still going through I'm still
getting chemo and I like last week I
just had a dose of chemo like this is
one key one more less instead of one
more like shoot I have one more I'm
getting a I'm getting chemo today like
Ah that's one less and then I'm done
playing four quarters of a game with my
brothers my coaches and all like my
family here like that's a win itself
there's a win coming up our heartwarming
videos ones you just got to see
including Sweet Moments from two huge
celebrities stick around you're watching
The Uplift
[Music]
next up when a brother brought a new
girlfriend home to meet the family the
family decided to pull a little prank
take a look
you guys ready for dinner
one nation under God indivisible with
liberty and justice for all
foreign
they're like what is going on this is
not normal uh I think she passed the
test I hope they have a long and happy
relationship all right take a look at
this next video uh it shows
eight-year-old Georgie approaching
Shaquille O'Neal courtside at a
basketball Day event big hug there from
Shack Shack denied the handshake but
brought him in for the big squeeze look
at that very sweet after seeing Shaq
show The Love Steve Harvey who was also
sitting there well he decided to come in
for a hug too
look at that
all right to our next video it shows
another star this time Jack Black at an
event to raise funds for a pediatric
hospice and palliative care organization
or Center he met a 15 year old boy there
named Abraham who said he's a big fan of
Jack Black's Film School of Rock I am as
well and his favorite part of the movie
is when Mr Black sings so what did Jack
Black do he got into character and sang
the song to Abraham
uh-huh and what song did he sing what
song does he sing
[Laughter]
yeah yes coming up when a boy left a
prize possession behind on an airplane a
group of co-workers came together to
rescue it plus that's the possession by
the way plus remembering Leslie Jordan
and the many ways he put a smile on our
faces throughout his long career putting
on a smile there lovely there
thank you
when an eight-year-old boy lost a toy
while traveling a group of co-workers
came together to make sure that toy was
returned and returned in one piece
here's Chris Van Cleef
glow Jones has been checking bags at
Burbank California's airport for two
decades but she'd never seen anything
like this a dinosaur the size of a small
child and he's scary looking but he was
really adorable eight-year-old Rowan
Francois got this guy on vacation with
no thought of how to get him home it's
almost as big as me I thought it was
going to break the whole time so you
were worried about it making it home
yeah but Southwest Airlines baggage
handler Brian Cisneros and his
co-workers were determined that wouldn't
happen when I saw it you know we locked
eyes and what he saw of VIP Rex in need
of very special treatment it wasn't in
the box so our concern was taking care
of it we gave it a specific Heart by
itself took it to the gates and when we
loaded the dinosaur in the bin we put it
in the center bin which is by himself
and when it finally got home to Spokane
I would like to show you other a one
more thing a reunion made possible Able
by going the extra mile
all is well it ends well we're going to
introduce you now to a marathon swimmer
a marathon swimmer who competes in one
of the most difficult Sports and we're
talking about only a teenager here's
Carter Evans with her story
as a child Maya marriage used to despise
swimming I hated it like my least
favorite thing to do but now at the wise
old age of 15. man that is cold she'll
happily Dive Into The Frigid Waters off
San Francisco Bay
saving lives with each stroke over the
past six years I've raised fifty
thousand dollars the money goes to
cancer research Maya started fundraising
when she was nine
competing in Open Water Events with swim
across America
by the time she was 13 she was crossing
Lake Tahoe
last summer while swimming the 20 miles
of open ocean between Catalina Island
and California Maya realized she wasn't
alone in the water I looked to the side
and just saw this giant eye and the
entire swim I thought it was a shark
wait you thought there was a shark
swimming along with you and you kept
going yeah when Maya gets scared or
tired she just thinks of the names on
her Swim Camp people battling cancer who
face a much bigger challenge I'm
swimming for them I'm doing it for them
and that's why I do these swims
[Applause]
[Music]
whatever motivates all right sweet story
there coming up our Anthony Mason spoke
to beloved actor Leslie Jordan just
weeks before Leslie passed away and the
star opened up to Anthony about the
recent Resurgence of his career
[Music]
our Anthony Mason spoke to beloved actor
Leslie Jordan just weeks before Jordan
died unexpectedly tragically as well the
star opened up about the recent
Resurgence of his career
well hello fellow honka downers Leslie
Jordan had long been a well-known
character actor so it has come to this
Arnon but the pandemic made him a star
what are y'all doing
this is awful
oh it's exhausting being
viral you like blew up give me a good
pandemic
it's still march
how many days in March I started posting
on Instagram and I did two posts a day I
think for 80 days
and then I don't know what happened
people have said to me what's the secret
I have no idea it would jump a million a
day he went from 80 000 followers to
nearly six million what were you
thinking at that point well I was just
thinking my gosh who are these people
they want to hear what I have to say it
was just a
the innocence of it I guess for decades
he'd worked steadily as an actor okay
Miss Phelan let's see what you got
playing Emma Stone's newspaper boss in
the help then the black veil was lifted
starring opposite Lady Gaga in American
Horror Story Karen Walker I thought I
smelled Jen and regret and sparring
memorably with Megan Mullally on Will
and Grace
well well well
that won him an Emmy but now that you've
got this persona
it's like you're in charge of that yeah
and sometimes I get tired of that it's
like they'll say
I'll do a tag or something I go
where did that let do that Leslie Jordan
thing okay okay what I can do whatever
that is I don't know what is it well
it's just bright and bubbly he'd always
been that way growing up in Chattanooga
Tennessee a popular kid but with a
secret I was a [ __ ] you know I was good
at sports my dad was a lieutenant
colonel in the Army he was a man's man
and his you know group of guys would
come home and I'd be twirling a baton in
the front yard yeah you know my mother
had taught me she was a champion baton
twirling Daddy watch me twirl and my
mother even I told her when I was about
12. she said I think you'll be subject
to ridicule and I couldn't bear that and
so just why don't why don't you just
live quietly
so here I am he caught the acting bug in
college at the University of Tennessee
at Chattanooga I was not one who did
plays in high school or you know I was
always funny but that was to keep the
bullies at Bay and I got up in that
intro to theater class and it just hit
me like a drug I mean I went I went to
the head of the department and I said
tell me what to do and he said well
first let's learn how to pronounce it
it's not theater
it's theater in 1982 Jordan headed out
to Hollywood I got a couple of
commercials and and got on a kind of a
roll with that I was the pit printing
guy I was the elevator operator to
Hamburger hail for Taco Bell where you
go if you don't eat hamburgers I guess
the name just kind of stuck in my head
the TV roles soon followed from an early
part as Candice Bergen's inept secretary
on Murphy Brown Kyle when they taught
you typing in prison did they mention
that the process tends to go faster if
you use both hands yeah but big Eddie
only taught us this way big Eddie big
Eddie one arm
to his latest sitcom call me cat with
Mayim Bialik I saw it winking at me in
women's petites and needless to say I
went back
in Nashville earlier this month we
watched him at work on a new project the
signs all say Tiny Terror Productions is
that you no no it out of me a music
video
[Music]
with the country duo LoCash and Blanco
Brown it was a late and unexpected
career turn when did you decide you
wanted to make records I had a
a Sunday Instagram hymn singing where we
would just sing these old hymns that I
grew up with
and people started tuning in and so
somehow from that we decided
to make an album tempted and tried we're
off made the Wonder it seems like you're
having a lot of fun with it oh my gosh
so unexpected just to happen at you know
in my 60s yeah
I'm a country music singer now
I love Nashville and the way that
Nashville
embraced me yeah you know and to be
taken kind of serious yeah and to have
made you know an album with Dolly Parton
Chris Stapleton yeah Brandi Carlisle
you know that's that's something it sure
was when the trumpets of the Lord shall
sound in time she'll be no more the last
moment we captured with Leslie Jordan he
sang for us with producer Danny Myrick
a favorite hymn When the Roll is Called
Up Yonder I've been baptized 13 times
just to make sure so I'm going to be
there
what a life and what a show I hope it
brightened your day it lifted you up I'm
confident it did and if it didn't you
know what I always say play it back
again reruns totally free I'm gonna go
find some good news
[Music]